[Music]
in maths we all know about the
pythagoras theorem
it says that if we have a triangle with
sides a b and c
then c squared gives us a squared plus b
squared where c is the hypotenuse
but how did we derive this formula
let's see let us take a line segment and
divide it into a and b
and in the same way we will draw a
square if we join all the four points
then we get a square let the length of
the sides of the square be c
the total area of the outer square will
be a plus b times a plus b which will be
a plus b the whole squared
the total area of the outer square will
be a plus b the whole squared which will
be a squared plus two a b plus b squared
and we know that the total area will be
equal to the sum of the smaller areas
so inside there are five areas the area
of the square is c squared
and there are four triangles with areas
one half times a b hence the sum of the
areas will be c squared plus 2 a b when
we equate them 2 a b gets cancelled and
we get a squared plus b squared equals c
squared and that proves the pythagoras
theorem